On pense toujours qu'il y a ces versions idéalisées des gens,
qu'ils montrent seulement les meilleures choses
qui leur sont arrivées dans la vie. Je l'ai pensé bien souvent.
Mes amis, impossible qu'ils soient si cool et qu'ils aient une vie si fantastique.
Eh bien, un étude a testé ça en examinant la personnalité des gens.
On a demandé à quatre bons amis d'une personne de juger sa personnalité
Et puis on a demandé à des inconnus, beaucoup d'inconnus
de juger sa personnalité uniquement à travers Facebook.
On a découvert que ces jugements sur la personnalité
étaient presque identiques, très corrélés,
c'est-à-dire que les profils Facebook reflètent vraiment notre personnalité.
Et les sites de rencontre en ligne, alors ?
C'est un espace plutôt trompeur.
Je suis sûr que vous avez des "amis" qui ont utilisé ces sites. (Rires)
Et ils vous parlent de ce type qui était chauve quand il s'est présenté,
de cette femme qui ne ressemblait pas du tout à sa photo...
Nous étions très intéressés par tout ça, alors
nous avons amené des gens qui utilisaient les rencontres en ligne dans notre laboratoire
et nous les avons mesurés. On a mesuré leur taille
contre le mur, leur poids sur la balance
-- les femme ont adoré -- et nous avons pris leur permis de conduire pour voir leur âge.
Ce que nous avons trouvé était vraiment très intéressant.
Voici un exemple des hommes et leur taille.
En bas il y a la hauteur déclarée sur le profil
et le long de l'axe y, l'axe vertical, il y a la taille réelle.
La ligne verticale est la ligne de la vérité. Si le point est sur cette ligne
ils disaient la vérité.
Comme vous voyez, la plupart des points sont en dessous de la ligne,
ça veut dire que les hommes mentaient sur leur taille.
En fait, ils ont menti sur leur taille d'environ deux centimètres
Comme on dit au labo "un fort arrondi supérieur". (Rires)
Vous faites 1,73 mètres et 2 centimètres, et boum! 1,75 mètres.
Mais ce qui est très important ici, regardez tous ces points.
Ils sont tous proches de la réalité. Ce qu'on a découvert
c'est que 80% des participants ont en effet menti
sur une de ces dimensions, mais ils ont toujours menti un tout petit peu.
Une des raisons est simple, Si vous avez un rendez-vous,
pour un café, et que vous êtes complètement différent de la description que vous avez donnée,
c'est terminé. Pas vrai? Donc les gens ont menti souvent, mais ont menti
subtilement, pas trop. Ils y étaient forcés.
Mais, que démontrent ces études? Qu'est-ce qui explique
qu'en dépit de nos intuitions, y compris les miennes,
la majeure partie de la communication en ligne, ou de celle qui a recours aux technologies,
est plus honnête qu'en face à face?
C'est très étrange. Comment est-ce qu'on explique ça ?
Eh bien, pour ce faire, on peut observer la littérature qui traite de détection de la tromperie.
C'est une littérature très ancienne maintenant, elle remonte à 50 ans.
Elle a été commentée bien des fois. Il y a eu des milliers d'essais,
des centaines d'études, et des découvertes fascinantes.
La première, on est très mauvais pour détecter les mensonges,
très mauvais. 54% d'exactitude en moyenne quand on doit dire
si quelqu'un qui vient de faire une déclaration ment ou pas.
C'est mauvais. Pourquoi est-ce si mauvais?
Eh bien c'est en rapport avec le nez de Pinocchio.
Si on devait vous demander à quoi vous vous fiez
quand vous regardez quelqu'un et vous voulez savoir
si il ment ? À quel signe prêtez-vous attention?
La plupart d'entre vous diraient qu'un des signes que vous guettez
ce sont les yeux. Les yeux sont les miroirs de l'âme.
Et vous n'êtes pas les seuls. Dans le monde entier, dans presque toutes les cultures,
un des premier signe, ce sont les yeux. Mails les études
de ces 50 dernières années disent qu'il n'y a aucun indice fiable
pour détecter un mensonge. Ça m'a épaté, et
je l'ai appris à mes dépends quand je travaillais dans les douanes.
Les yeux ne disent pas si quelqu'un ment ou non.
Dans certains cas, oui -- de grands enjeux, peut-être que les pupilles se dilatent,
la voix devient plus aiguë, les mouvements du corps changent un petit peu,
mais pas tout le temps, pas tout le monde, ce n'est pas fiable.
C'est étrange. L'autre chose, c'est que si vous ne me voyez pas
ça ne veut pas dire que je vais mentir. C'est logique,
mais une découverte importante est que nous avons une raison de mentir.
On ment pour se protéger, ou dans notre propre intérêt.
ou celui de quelqu'un d'autre
Il y a des menteurs pathologiques, mais ils représentent
une infime partie de la population. On ment pour une raison.
Ce n'est pas parce qu'on ne nous voit pas
que nous allons forcément mentir.
Mais je pense qu'il y a quelque chose de bien plus
intéressant et fondamental qui se passe ici.
L'étape majeure suivante, la prochaine grande idée, on la trouve en remontant
très loin dans l'histoire des origines du language.
La plupart des linguistes s'accordent à dire que le langage est apparu il y a de ça
entre 50 000 et 100 000 ans. C'était il y a très longtemps.
Beaucoup d'humains ont vécus entre temps.
On a parlé, je pense de feux et de cavernes
et de tigres à dents de sabre. Je sais pas de quoi ils parlaient,
mais ils parlaient beaucoup, et comme je l'ai dit
les humains évoluent beaucoup en parlant
environ 100 milliards de personnes en fait.
Ce qui est important cependant, c'est que l'écriture n'est apparue qu'il y a
environ 5 000 ans. Ça signifie que
tous les gens, avant qu'il n'y ait la moindre écriture,
chaque mot jamais prononcé, chaque déclaration
a disparu. Aucune trace. Evanoui. Parti.
Donc on a évolué pour parler d'une manière
qui n'a pas laissé de trace. En fait, même le prochain grand changement
de l'écriture ne s'est passé qu'il y a 500 ans,
avec l'imprimerie, dans un passé très récent,
et le taux d'alphabétisation est resté incroyablement bas jusqu'à la deuxième guerre mondiale.
Alors même les gens des deux derniers millénaires,
la plupart des mots qu'ils ont pu dire -- pouf ! -- disparus.
Revenons à aujourd'hui, l'ère des réseaux.
Combien d'entre vous ont enregistré quelque chose aujourd'hui ?
Quelqu'un a écrit quelque chose aujourd'hui ? Est-ce que quelqu'un a écrit un mot ?
On dirait que presque chacun d'entre vous a enregistré quelque chose.
Dans cette salle, là tout de suite, nous avons surement enregistré plus
que presque toute la pré-histoire de l'humanité.
C'est fou. Nous entrons dans une période extraordinaire
de flux dans l'évolution humaine où nous avons évolué pour parler
de telle façon que nos mots disparaissaient, mais nous sommes dans
un environnement où l'on enregistre tout.
En fait, je pense que dans un futur très proche, ce n'est pas seulement
ce qu'on écrit qui sera enregistré, tout ce que nous faisons
sera enregistré.
Qu'est-ce que ça signifie ? Quelle est la prochaine grande idée qui va en sortir ?
Eh bien, en tant que chercheur en sciences sociales, c'est la chose la plus incroyable
dont j'ai jamais rêvé. Maintenant, je peux regarder tous
ces mots qui, pendant des millénaires, disparaisaient.
Je peux regarder des mensonges qu'auparavant, on disait et qui disparaissaient ensuite.
Vous vous rappelez ces bidonnages dont on a parlé
tout à l'heure ? Et bien lorsqu'on écrit un faux commentaire,
on doit le poster quelque part, et il y reste notre disposition.
Alors ce que nous avons fait, et je vais vous donner un exemple
tiré de l'observation du langage, c'est que nous avons payé des gens
pour écrire des faux commentaires. Un de ces commentaire est un faux.
La personne n'a jamais été au James Hotel.
L'autre est un vrai commentaire. La personne y a séjourné.
Maintenant, vous devez décider
lequel des deux est le faux commentaire.
Je vous donne un moment pour les lire.
Mais à la fin je veux que tout le monde lève la main.
Rappelez-vous, j'ai étudié le mensonge. Je sais si vous ne levez pas la main.
Ok, combien d'entre vous pensent que A est le faux commentaire
Bon, très bien, environ la moitié.
Et combien d'entre vous pensent que c'est B ?
Bien, un peu plus.
Excellent. Voilà la réponse.
B est un faux. Bravo, le deuxième groupe. Vous l'avez remporté sur le premier groupe. (Rires)
Vous êtes en fait un peu inhabituels. À chaque fois qu'on fait cette démonstration,
c'est souvent autour de 50-50, ce qui correspond
aux recherches, et à 54%. Peut-être que les gens ici
à Winnipeg sont plus soupçonneux et meilleurs pour trouver les menteurs.
Ces hivers froids et rigoureux, j'adore ça.
Bon, donc pourquoi ça m'intéresse ?
Ehbien, maintenant avec mes collègues informaticiens
nous pouvons créer un algorithme pour analyser
les indices linguistiques du mensonge.
Permettez-moi de mettre en évidence deux ou trois choses dans
ce faux commentaire. La première, c'est que les menteurs ont tendance à penser
à la forme de leur récit. Ils inventent une histoire :
Qui ? Que s'est-il passé ? Et c'est ce qu'on retrouve ici.
Nos faux commentateurs ont raconté avec qui ils étaient
et ce qu'ils ont fait. Ils ont aussi utilisé la première personne du singulier, je,
beaucoup plus que les personnes qui ont réellement séjourné là-bas.
Ils se mettent en scène dans le commentaire sur l'hôtel,
en tentant en quelque sorte de vous convaincre qu'ils y étaient.
Au contraire, les personnes qui ont écrit les commentaires et qui étaient vraiment sur place,
leur corps étaient dans l'espace physique,
ils donnaient beaucoup plus d'informations spatiales.
Ils décrivaient la taille de la salle de bain, ou il disaient,
si les magasins étaient loin de l'hôtel.
Vous avez été plutôt bons. La plupart des gens répondent au hasard.
Notre algorithme est très précis, bien plus précis
que les êtres humains, mais il ne le sera pas à tous les coups.
Ce n'est pas un détecteur de mensonge qui dira
si votre copine vous ment dans ses textos.
Nous pensons que tous les mensonges, tous les types de mensonge --
les faux commentaires d'hôtel, les faux commentaires pour des chaussures
votre copine qui vous trompe via des textos --
ce sont des mensonges différents. Ils vont avoir des
modèles de langage différents.Mais puisque tout
est enregistré maintenant, nous pouvons examiner tous ces types de mensonges.
Comme je l'ai dit, en tant que chercheur en sciences sociales, c'est magnifique.
Ça change tout, nous allons être capables d'en apprendre
tellement plus sur la pensée et l'expression humaines,
sur tout, de l'amour aux attitudes,
parce que tout est enregistré maintenant, mais
qu'est-ce que ça veut dire pour le citoyen ordinaire ?
Qu'est-ce que ça représente pour nous, dans nos vies ?
Et bien, oublions la tromperie pour un petit moment. Une des grandes idées,
selon moi, c'est que nous laissons ces énormes traces derrière nous.
La boîte d'envoi de mes courriels est impressionnante
et je n'y jette jamais un coup d'oeil. J'écris tout le temps,
mais je ne regarde jamais mes traces écrites.
Et je pense qu'on va voir ça de plus en plus,
que nous pouvons réfléchir à qui nous sommes en regardant
ce que nous avons écrit, dit, ou fait.
Si on ramène ça au mensonge, on peut
retenir dux ou trois choses ici.
Premièrement, mentir en ligne peut être très dangereux, n'est-ce pas?
Non seulement vous laissez une trace sur votre machine
mais vous laissez une trace sur la personne à qui vous mentez,
et vous en laissez aussi pour que je puisse les analyser
à l'aide d'algorithmes
Alors faites donc, faites-le, c'est bien.
Mais quand il s'agit de mentir et de ce que nous voulons faire
de nos vies, je pense qque nous pouvons revenir à
Diogenes et Confucius. Ils s'inquiétaient moins
de mentir ou pas, et se souciaient plus
d'être honnête avec eux-mêmes, et je pense que c'est très important.
Quand vous allez dire ou faire quelque chose,
on peut penser, est-ce que je veux vraiment laisser ça derrière moi,
que ça fasse partie de mes archives personnelles ?
Parce qu'à l'ère numérique dans laquelle nous vivons,
à l'ère des réseaux, nous laissons tous des archives.
Merci beaucoup de m'avoir accordé de votre temps,
et bonne chance avec vos archives. (Applaudissements)